last night and if you saw this the Today
Show team hosted the lighting of the
Rockefeller Christmas tree there was no
mention of Matt Lauer no mention the NBC
executive said we think one exposed
piece of wood is enough for tonight
[Applause]
what was their growing acceptance of
that joke cause the tree and then cousin
home I was weird yeah yesterday Matt
Lauer got a public message of support
from Geraldo Rivera yeah and response
Lauer said my god now I've really hit my
bottom
when Geraldo Rivera comes to your ad I'm
to get out of the bats when you know
you've done something wrong what else is
going on
two large properties associated with
Donald Trump have decided to
disassociate from him big story that's a
big deal yeah yeah one is the Trump Soho
hotel and the other is the Kremlin so
[Laughter]
that's really all I thought it would get
a sixth woman has come forward to accuse
senator Al Franken of sexually
inappropriate behavior yeah on the plus
side if Franken resigns the senator from
Minnesota he can still be elected the
senator from Alabama switch over of
course I'm talking about Roy Moore it's
come out that Roy Moore once co-authored
a text book which argues that women
shouldn't run for public office
yeah that's really surprising since his
current girlfriend is currently running
for hall monitor so another one where
there was growing acceptance Oh
[Music]
Pope Francis been traveling you got some
trouble this week Pope Francis visited a
Buddhist country made some controversial
comments yeah the worst was when the
Pope saw a statue of Buddha and said hey
at least my god has abs okay the Pope
said it not me that was the Pope I agree
the Pope's have that's a bad guy anyway
an Ohio based company an Ohio based
company made a cup holder for dip that
attaches to a dashboard so you can eat
chips and dip while you drive ladies and
gentlemen I don't have a joke about this
I just wanted to remind you we are still
the greatest country
oh yeah then you work the stick shift
not sure what better way to arrive at
your destination covered in dip yeah
exactly
Andy's the spokesman for this product so
if you like getting dip on yourself try
this thing yeah
you